today what I'm going to talk about is a
research paper or review article talking
about the origin of the new coronavirus
that's wreaking havoc everywhere and
essentially asking the question where
did it come from and as previously
mentioned this is a review article so
this is summarizing around 30 different
research articles from from different
fields and different types of research
and I'm gonna talk about many of those
but first I just want to give you an
introduction to me and kind of my
scientific past so I'm originally from
Virginia and where I grew up but after
college I moved to New York and stay
with my grandmother here in this nice
cozy New York City apartment and during
that time I also luckily found a career
in scientific research and so over the
past 10 years or so I've been studying
and working in a lab and so this is let
me switch to the pointer and so this is
this is me in a lab and I typically
study things related to DNA and right
now I'm studying how DNA is organized in
a Cell so as you all might know DNA it's
really long so if you took a single cell
and stretched out all the DNA it would
actually be much taller than me about
the size of Michael Jordan it would be
and that all that DNA has to fit in a
very tiny cell and it organizes itself
in different ways and that's what I'm
currently studying at Rockefeller
University but what I've been curious
about also is how DNA and other genetic
information give rise to evolution in
different traits and men
be talking about that in light of the
viral evolution at the coronavirus okay
so this is me
currently with my partner and our cozy
New York City apartment trying to
maintain our mental health by doing some
yoga I've also been doing some some
sewing projects as well and I don't know
if y'all can see this but there's a
cookie inside of this mug so we've been
doing a lot of baking and a couple of
cookies a day is also helping keep our
spirits up during these these trying
times okay so now to the research so the
as the as Jenny mentioned the name of
this research is called the proximal
origin of Tsarskoe b2 or as I'll refer
to it as the new corona virus and this
question that they're asking is
essentially when did the new corona
virus as pictured in a cartoon here
become deadly to humans and again this
is a correspondence or view article but
there are still many different authors
from different parts of the world that
have collaborated together to write and
critically think about this topic but
you also notice that something quite you
know outstanding here is that this
article has been viewed 4.2 almost 4.3
million times by different people
throughout the world in a very short
time and one of the reasons for this is
because of implications that this
article talks about is is whether or not
this new corona virus was a result of
bioterrorism which has been debunked but
and and their rationale I'll present to
you today but also I want to present to
you the rationale of where they think it
might have come from and became deadly
to humans I also want to kind of tell
you the techniques that were
that allow us to track genetic changes
so that's also part of the the goal of
this talk and I just want to
re-emphasize that even though the
authors didn't do the research they did
do a lot of or there are many authors
and they are coming from different parts
of the world
a couple within the United States
there's also some in Australia and in
Edinburgh University of UK but a lot of
the research has been done in China but
also different parts of the world so
this is really a collaborative event and
just highlighting that science is such a
important thing to cooperate so before
we get into talking about the actual
research and the discussion underlying
it I want to go over a few key terms so
I know the central dogma was reviewed in
this series last week but I also want to
review it just briefly and then also I'm
going to be talking about important
region of the coronavirus protein called
the receptor binding domain I'll also be
talking about this technique called
sequence alignment and how that is used
to watch the evolution how we track the
evolution of the virus through that and
using this idea of a molecular clock
okay so so we have our virus here and
inside the virus there is this gene
material or or genome as I might refer
to it sometimes and this in the virus is
an RNA molecule in humans this is a DNA
molecule but the virus has RNA and this
material is the the founding material
that gets started and tells it's the
information how to build the cell this
material then gets transcribed
essentially copied like you would just
transcribe a note into what we call
messenger RNA which is just an
intermediate stage that allows the cell
to take this information and then
convert it into protein which is a
really important part and this is called
translation and the reason this is
called translation is because it's in
some sense a different language even
though it's directly based off of this
RNA language that it's coming from and
this language has what we refer to as
different kind of letters or we refer to
as amino acids so these are just
abbreviations for those amino acids so
you can see that YH T vs they're just
shorthand and they're organized in this
linear string and these encode for the
very functional parts of the cell the
proteins that execute the tasks so for
example y'all might have heard of a
spike domain order spike protein and so
this is important for the infectiousness
of the virus and I'm going to talk a
little bit more about this protein and
its different domains but before that I
just also want to remind you all that
this genetic element here the the RNA of
the virus it needs to be able to
replicate itself and during this
replication this can sometimes cause
mutations and these mutations generally
happen randomly but essentially like
making it in an air and these errors can
be propagated and continued on into the
next virus past alone okay so we have
our protein words made out of our amino
acid so-called letters but these can be
expanded on just like we can create
words into sentences and give it more
information and so for for proteins how
this works is that they this linear
organization of the the amino acids then
can fold into different structures and
shapes that allowed to give it different
tasks
within a cell and this can be even more
complicated and you give more context to
how this domain works with different
parts there are different domains of a
protein or with different even more
proteins and so what I'm showing here
this green one this is actually the
receptor binding domain that's found in
the corona virus the new Perona virus
and this domain is really important for
its ability to interact with cells that
Express this ace to receptor so these
cells include the human lungs and other
different tissues but the lungs are one
of the most prevalent one that expressed
this receptor and this receptor binding
domain as the name suggests helps it
bind to the cell and then allows it
eventually to interact air to enter the
cell and become infectious so the way we
think about these different shapes are
kind of like this very classic toy in
which you have shapes that corresponds
to different different receptors so for
example this one here would fit nicely
in this small hole whereas it might fit
within these other ones but it might not
be as snug or as compatible so it might
fall out more easily so that's kind of
how we think about proteins and their
shapes and how that informs different
interactions in the cell okay and so now
the technique that is most used and
talked about in this research review is
this technique called sequence alignment
and this can be done with the RNA
sequence the genes but what we're going
to talk about is just the protein
sequence and so the goal of this is just
this it's similar to a search front
function or find if you want to find all
the things that are similar
they don't necessarily have to be the
exact sequence but you can see that you
want align the sequences up so that they
are most similar even though there are
some differences here yeah so
essentially just finding things that are
similar or related to each other and one
of the things that this does is allows
us to identify those amino acids those
that stay the same and those might give
us some insight into the structure and
what kind of structures are important
for the protein to create different
shapes but also what things that the
virus might need to always maintain some
other ones that are more mutated and
changed are often those that can evolve
and take different shapes and those also
might be important for understanding the
evolution of the protein in the virus in
general and so what we can do is use
this alignment technique to essentially
map the what we call it as a lineage but
is essentially trying to understand who
came first and then who gave rise to the
next one in the next one just like we
think about our great-grandparents or
grandparents and then all the way down
to their child so the way this works is
essentially we take those sequences that
are most similar and those that we think
are the most distant ancestors or
relatives and then we look at the
difference the next one we'll map is the
one that has only a slight difference so
in this case is s changed to a T but
otherwise it's the same sequence and so
this is likely to be the next step of a
mutation that occurred but this T is is
maintained throughout the rest of
these is passed on and and then other
mutations can build off of that and
create more changes and so this is the
way we track time essentially in a in a
genetic or in a genetic lineage because
proteins are all ultimately coming from
the genes okay
so now we reviewed these key terms we
have the central dogma which is
essentially going from genes to proteins
and these proteins are functioning in
the cell and have like tasks and the one
protein domain that we talked about of
the corona virus is this receptor
binding domain which is really important
for its ability to interact with some of
the cells in humans in the ACE to
receptor and then we talked about the
sequence alignment which is essentially
just identifying who's related who's in
the family who's come into the cookout
the next is a molecular clock using this
sequence alignment to essentially trace
lineage and see who came first
who's the intermediate and who's the
most recent one okay and because this is
a review article that's encompassing
many different types of research I'm
just gonna go over the different styles
of scientific reasoning because there
are many types of side ways to create
scientific knowledge so one of the first
ways is this categorization in
classification and in this paper
essentially what that means is
collecting the genes and the genomes of
different viruses
okay so sequencing the the genes and
compiling them and then there is the
historical based evolutionary reasoning
so these are different ways of thinking
that have been established in the
evolutionary field that give us ways to
interpret the data that I'll talk about
then lastly there's this hypothetical
modelling which is essentially taking
computer math equations that build off
each other and use different different
scenarios to calculate different
possible things so you've probably heard
this in the context of modeling for the
amount of cases of coronavirus that are
I'm going to happen in different
populations and those can be changing
depending on the human behavior what I
want to talk about is hypothetical
modeling of proteins in the structure of
proteins but first I just want to review
that the overall goal of this study was
to determine how the new coronavirus
emerged and when it became deadly in
humans okay so the authors discussed
three possibilities so one is that the
corona virus originated in animals and
that the current deadly form to humans
originated in animals and jumped to
humans and then began to spread from
human to human and it was already quite
deadly the alternative hypothesis is
that that it began in in animals in a
kind of intermediate phase where it
wasn't as deadly and it jumped to humans
and then it passed from human to human
and that allowed it to adopt its more
deadly form and lastly what people have
also talked about is that it's possible
being made in a lab and this is largely
being debunked as a form of bioterrorism
and I'm going to talk about the the
reasons in the paper that they give for
this rationale oh so but first I want to
talk about this these it's starting
in animals and so a lot of people have
heard of the corona virus in
relationship to the bat because the bats
do have a lot of corona viruses
different types but there's also this
other animal that I didn't know about
until I started researching for this
talk and I just wanted to you know step
back and take a poll and see if anybody
else recognizes this animal and knows
what kind of animal it is or oh this is
you know really everybody's really good
and so the possibilities are that it's
an anteater it's an armadillo
it's a Pangolin or it's super cute and a
lot of people are nailing it right see
is the most accurate
it's a Pangolin which is a small mammal
it is also a okay I have to
share results sorry I can't get the pole
out of here
alright I will take it off okay so but
they're also super cute too so that was
also a valid answer so I spent a whole
afternoon now I can't move to the next
slide so I spent a whole afternoon
looking at pictures of baby penguins
which are essentially a real life baby
Yoda and so they're super adorable but
they also unfortunately harbor the new
relatives of the new coronavirus and so
how the data that the research is
talking about was collected was that the
cells from different animals including
from that so actually from bats it was
taken from bat droppings and the
sequences that most people know from
bats actually come from about seven
years ago whereas the sequence that come
from pangolins actually come from a very
recent so within the past few months
there was a Pangolin that died from
corona virus like symptoms and that was
in a wildlife refugee and they took the
cells and sequenced their material their
genetic material and this has an
asterisks here because sequencing the
genetic material from viruses from
animals is very difficult when this
genetic material is sequenced a lot of
it is actually coming from either the
bat or the Pangolin itself so very
little of it is actually coming from the
viruses and thus there is a really
incomplete catalogue of all the viruses
that
that have been sequenced but the ones
that have been sequence what we've done
with that or what they've done with it
is they've use that to make sequence
alignments and determine how related
different viruses are to each other
and so the general overview is that
there's highly related bat coronavirus
so 96% to the new coronavirus so overall
it's very very similar but there's also
a Pangolin coronavirus that is 91%
similar so it's also very highly similar
and it has a really interesting unique
signature that I'm gonna talk about in a
second and then the SARS coronavirus so
this is the 2003 generally refer to just
as SARS this is less related about 80%
related okay and then also this receptor
binding domain has the most changes okay
and so the data that they present in the
paper is essentially what this is this
pink bar is just a cartoon of protein
with all of its amino acids so this is
what they're showing is the spike
protein and these numbers refer to the
amino acids that happen in just right
next to each other just in this kind of
line and what you can see are these blue
lines here and those are indicating
important changes in this receptor
binding domain and so if we zoom in a
little bit closer what you can see is
what they have is the human stars Coby
to the new corona virus they have the
bat coronavirus that's 96% similar and
then the pen goal and coronavirus and
the original SARS coronavirus and two
more distantly related ones and so what
you can see is that the bat in is very
closely related to the new corona virus
but there are some key
amino acid changes that exists between
the bat and the new coronavirus but so
this F and this L this Q and this Y this
s and R and these other ones here but
these also are found in the Pangolin so
they're actually very very similar to
the ones that are found and they're
known to be very important for the
binding of the corona virus to the ACE
to receptor that allows it to infect the
lungs in other cells so even though the
bat is the bat coronavirus is the most
related to this one the piquillo bangle
and one has this really unique signature
that's really important for the
infectiousness so this indicates that
the new corona virus likely comes from a
natural source because of its high
identity to the background virus and the
signature found in pangolins that is
already existing in nature so this is
one strong argument for it not being
created in a lab and so I'm going to
talk about just briefly this other site
that you can see that there's some other
important changes and this is referred
to as the cleavage site and the cleavage
site is is just generally important for
not the binding of the receptor of the
virus protein to the h2 receptor but
instead the entry into the cell but what
you can see here is that this new
coronaviruses has this amino acid
signature that none of these not the
Pangolin nor the bat coronaviruses have
so this is likely something but more
recently changed and and this has also
been confirmed in in experiments that it
is important for the infectiousness of
the corona virus in humans
okay so now it's time to talk about the
interpretation of this data so those are
the major findings and the question is
whether this virus originated the
deadliness of this virus originated in
animals or in humans and we already
talked about that it's very unlikely
that it didn't originate in a lab but
we're gonna do another poll and see what
what everyone thinks
okay so this one wasn't as easy as the
Pangolin question and the reason why is
I guess because of that is
it's because it's it's not clear so
that's one of the reasons why
okay sorry I can't get out of this one
as well
[Music]
can you just X out o stop sharing yeah
okay and so that's one of the reasons
why people often write review articles
is because there are some unanswered
questions in the field so authors
suggest that this receptor binding
domain because it's so similar to the
one that's seen in the pen Golan's this
part was already mutated in some animal
it could have been bets it could have
been an Golan's and then jumped to
humans and it's possible that this
cleavage domain was already existing
than - but it's also possible that it
this cleavage domain made those
important changes while I'm transferring
to human to human and the authors say
that more scientific data could swing
the balance of this in evidence to favor
one hypothesis of the other so that
means that there's still an open window
on this question and some of the things
that could be used to answer this is if
they find viruses from animals and that
that do match it more similar that would
indicate this kind of hypothesis they
could also use sequences of viruses that
come from humans before the outbreak
started and that might favor that might
shift into this hypothesis okay and so
as we mentioned this is unlikely but
we're gonna also talk about some of the
other reasons the author mentioned that
this is not only unlikely but it's very
unlikely okay so the one thing that we
mentioned previously is that there's a
natural signature so from the sequence
alignment just the uncanny similarity
between those found in nature really
suggests that it is a product of
evolution in in humans or in animals or
in starting at least
but there's also this really important
reason is that because viruses they they
don't we can't it's not very easy to
isolate a virus because there are also
many different viruses within one cell
or one sample and so when we isolate the
viruses in sample in in the lab we often
add these DNA signatures to them and
these DNA's or in this case it would be
RNA sorry ID we add these genes to them
that allow us to track them and
manipulate them and make them very easy
and otherwise it's it's it's really very
difficult to work with those and edit
them or manipulate them in ways that
would be necessary for bioterrorism
agent so all the sequences that have
been found thus far lack any some kind
of signature that is found in the lab
both in humans or an animal's so none of
those exist another reason is using
modeling data for the protein structure
interaction between the receptor binding
domain and the ace 2 receptor so what
researchers found out is that the
structure and the shapes of the receptor
binding domain that are found in the new
Corunna virus even though they are very
infectious and make everyone stick
they're more like taking one of these
little circles and putting it in in this
big hole and where it doesn't really fit
it can fit there but it's not really
snug and so they suggest if that
somebody were to create a bioterrorist
agent then it would create something
that is more more snugly fit more
efficient at doing its job and in
becoming more infectious ok and so the
general conclusions are that the new
corona virus has a
mature that's occurring in nature it has
the highest sequence similarity to a
virus found in bats it has a receptor
binding domain signature of a virus
that's found in pangolins and this is
quite recent this virus infecting in the
Pangolin it has a a cleavage site that's
also important for its function but this
is more recent and it's not clear in
what Oregon in what animal are in humans
it was it originated okay and then also
the receptor binding domain is not
optimized to bind for the human ace to
receptor suggesting that it's not
engineered and it also lacks any
signature of lab engineering ok and just
to review this paper used a couple of
different methods it used the
categorization and classification so
that's essentially taking and sampling
as many virus genes or genomes that we
could find in nature and and one thing
to note about this is that we don't have
a complete collection of all the genes
and genomes of viruses found in
different animals so there might be some
that come to light that change our
interpretations of this okay so there's
also historical based evolutionary
reasoning that we used and one thing to
note is determining the original
ancestor so this is often in difficult
mostly because of this incompleteness of
the genomes and so this is something
that researchers are still trying to do
is determine the original most recent
ancestor of this virus
and then these hypothetical model is
that I talked about the protein
structure not being optimal these are
being confirmed in living cells and
using these models to predict those
different more efficient structures and
a lot of these a lot of what is known
from the predictions are are turning out
to be accurate okay and so why is this
kind of question important other than
knowing that it wasn't an act of
bioterrorism this research can help in
many different ways so we can know for
example which animals can be hosts to
the virus so this could prevent future
transfers of the virus from animals to
humans but it also could help us stop
spreading the virus in animals so that
might be an important way to just stop
spread the virus top spreading the virus
but we can also track using the same
techniques track the ongoing evolution
of the virus and we can essentially look
how the virus is being transmitted from
one population to another using the same
kind of the same kind of techniques of
this sequence alignment and then lastly
these protein models can also help give
us information about what areas of the
protein to target when we create drugs
or vaccines and so that's also very
important
[Music]